die halbmast versicherung findet beim
klettern in der seilschaft beim abseilen
ablassen und beim bau von verankerungen
verwendung das seil wird in den highways
karabiner eingehängt
das la style wird in
richtung zu einer schlinge eingedreht
und eingehängt
mit dem typischen umschlagen des knotens
kann dieser gut auf richtigkeit
überprüft werden
die halb marsdorf sicherung muss so
angelegt sein dass beim ablassen oder
bei einem sturz das bremsseil über den
geschlossenen schenkel einläuft
ein möglichst zum la style paralleles
ein laufendes bremsseil assist zu
bevorzugen da dadurch die kranke bildung
verringert wird